but like when i open twitter
i'm energized there's a lot of love on
twitter people say like
i love to i agree i have you don't think
i have a lot of love on twitter my fans
pay my rent
i mean i don't know your experience of
twitter but when i look at your
which is a fundamentally different thing
i'm saying my experience from the
so maybe you can tell me what your
experience is like as a human so when i
observe your twitter i think
i i don't i wouldn't call it love i
would call it
fun yes and because of that
that's a different kind of like love
emerges from that
because people kind of learn that we're
having this is like game
night like yes uh you know we're we can
talk
a little bit we can uh and you can
you can even like pull in you can make
fun of people you can have the crazy
uncle come over
that is a huge trump supporter or
somebody who hates trump and you can
have a little fun yes
i get it's a different kind of thing i i
wouldn't be able to um
uh be the you're the host of game night
yes yes
so i wouldn't be able to host that kind
of game night yeah i
imagine you programming your robots and
you're asking what is fun and it just
starts sparkling
exactly yeah what is fun
[Laughter]
so the robots in my life that survive
are the ones that
that don't that like survive that whole
programming uh process so they're kind
of like
they're kind of like the idiot from
dostoevsky they're very like
simple-minded
robots it's just one is moving a can
from one table to another
yeah that's game night for uh for our
kin
you know what i'm on my quotes is and i
i think about this every day and i mean
it with every fiber of my being
we're born knowing that life is a
magical adventure and it takes them
years to train us to think otherwise and
i think that willy wonka approach it's a
very camus approach it's something i
believe with every fiber of my being
i try to spread that as much as possible
i think it is very sad
i'm not being sarcastic i this it comes
off as condescending i mean it at face
value
it's very sad how many people are not
receptive to that and i think a lot of
those functions how they were raised
and i i could have very easily with my
upbringing
have not maintained that perspective
and there's a lot of i have a lot of
friends in recovery
like a.a and they have an expression um
not my circus not my monkeys right that
you can't really
take on other people's problems on your
own at a certain point they have to do
the work themselves because you can only
do so much
externally and there are a lot of very
damaged people out there and there are
damaged people
who revel in being damaged and they are
damaged people who desperately
desperately desperately want to be well
who desperately want to be happy who
desperately want to find joy
so if i can be the one and as arrogant
as it sounds i'll on it
who does give them that fun and to tell
them it doesn't have to be like you you
thought
like it could be it's gonna hurt it's
gonna suck
but it's still a magical adventure and
you're gonna be okay because you've been
through worse
like that if that could be my message i
would own it all day long
and so what does adventure look like for
you because i mean it actually boils
down to i still disagree with you i
think
trolling can can be and
very often as destructive for society
you yes i want to destroy society
that is the goal i want i want to help
many people
ironically okay ironically yes
uh what do i do with that okay so
whatever you want do without will
is the hall of the law um like i just
wanna so you're hosting game night and i
just wanna play monopoly i wanna play
uh what's the risk okay i wanna play
these games and you're saying that's the
games
yeah i was trying to think like of a
friendlier game they're all kind of
aggressive
uh battleship actors and allies you know
fun stuff
but like uh so that's an adventure but
you're saying
that we want to destroy everything even
like
the rules of those games are are not
like you voluntarily agree to those
rules the point is if someone comes in
who's not who no one invited to game
night and are telling you no
when you play monopoly you have to get
money when you land in free parking or
you don't
yeah it's like who are you yeah we're
having our own fun
and you smell
i don't know but there there's a an
aggressive
there's an aggression let me let me
speak to that which i think you're
picking up on
uh i had a friend named martha marcia
excuse me she ran something called
cuddle parties which people laughed at
about a lot
back in the day and the premise of the
cuddle parties everyone got together and
cuddled right and it's like ah
then you stop to think about and you
realize uh physical contact is extremely
important
and a lot of people don't have it and if
this is a mechanism of people getting
that it actually is going to have
profound positive psychological
consequences so after she explained i'm
like okay
we laughed at this because it's weird
and now that i think about it this is
wonderful
and and i asked her about like like the
tough question i go
what if guys get turned on and on their
website it even has a rule like do not
fear the erection right because it's
going to be a natural consequence of
physical proximity
and the point she goes she she said this
i think about us all the time
people will take as much space as you
let them it is incumbent on each of us
to set our own boundaries we all have to
learn when to say no
you're making me uncomfortable if
someone doesn't respect your right
to have your boundary to be
uncomfortable this person is not your
friend now
they can say i don't understand like why
is this okay why is that not i let me
know you better so i'm respectful of you
but if they roll their eyes and they're
like get over i'm gonna do what i want
this person is not interested in knowing
as a human being
okay that is the aggression it is you
have to draw those lines
i mean but that's a very positive way of
phrasing that aggression
i'm a very positive person
you